anyway our primetime special Conan
Israel is airing next Tuesday September
19th at 10:00 p.m. right here on TBS and
I have to tell you we had a lot of
laughs during our trip as we was we do
I've traveled in many countries and have
had a lot of laughs we had a lot of
laughs in Israel but there of course
some serious moments too like the day we
visited the city of Bethlehem
including a stop at the separation wall
that divides Israel and the West Bank
that's a pretty powerful place to visit
and obviously that's going to be part of
the special as well
and so we just want to show you a quick
clip of that moment it's very quick
right now I'm standing on the
Palestinian side of the wall that is in
the West Bank it separates the
Palestinians from the Israelis like any
wall of this nature you can see that
it's I mean it was put up it became a
canvas for people who wanted to express
their feelings of anger but many people
on this side of the wall consider to be
a form of apartheid or oppression an
occupation Banksy has done paintings
here and it's also a flashpoint there's
been a lot of violence here a lot of
clashes between the Israeli forces and
Palestinians rock throwing tear gas
killings it can be a violent place and
of course right here the ultimate symbol
of divisive Nostromo apparently he
thinks it's his fourth wife
he seems happy it looks like he finally
got his wall after all many tones in the
show was written tap here in 40 minutes
but we're really proud of the show so be
sure to watch our primetime special
Conan in Israel airing next Tuesday
that's this coming Tuesday September
19th at 10 o'clock p.m.
also check out be sure if you can it's
such a hard story to tell in such a
short period of time so check out all of
the many Conan and Israel extras at Team
koco.com slash Israel because there is
so much more if you go on the website
you